the jurogan experience there's two
deathbed stories that i heard
all right one of them was uh should i
tell the sad one
or the the cool one first it's up to you
okay i'll tell the cool one first okay
we'll land in a dark place
um so i remember hearing lou reed when
lou reed was on his deathbed
he was just sitting there relaxed
smiling with this look of like
wonderment like enjoying
this ex your last experience yeah i'm
going to experience
death and he was open to it and and
had like a little smile on his face and
it's just like okay that's
how i would like to go out not being
like oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
and then there was another one i almost
don't even want to say the [ __ ] name
i'm not a gun i was this famous guy
and he he was a child star and i don't
think he ever got past
that you know the ups and downs i was
here and and now i'm only here but he's
still like doing these huge shows but
he's not as big as he was
and his his final words were so much
wasted time
and if you look at his career it wasn't
he worked his ass off but then i'm
that's what scares the [ __ ] out of me
i'm like so much wasted time dude you
played [ __ ] theaters for 40 years
selling out and made millions of dollars
and you came out the other side with the
of
with of that was saying so much wasted
time
so that's kind of making me look at like
uh you know
it's it's this is weird sort of thing
with what what we do
like oh this it's exciting and stuff and
but you know you kind of also sit back
like all right well i'm doing if i if i
do that too much
and something else suffers or did i i
take the time
like uh you know i have a pool i'm never
in it
so it's just this expensive puddle like
what am i doing with this [ __ ] thing
and it's like comes over to maintain
your puddle dude and that was the dream
i remember like
living in play [ __ ] new york no air
conditioners like someday i'm gonna get
a [ __ ] house
and i'm gonna have a [ __ ] pool and on
a goddamn day like this so i'm gonna
[ __ ] jump into that thing
and uh yeah and on hot days like that
i'm not i'm [ __ ]
sitting in my office you know working
but there's something to be said about
that because that's what you're supposed
to do as a dad and everything but then
um you know there's also that other
thing it's like if you work too much do
you end up being that guy
laying there you probably will yeah you
know that's joe the thing about those
guys well if you work too much i'm
saying
i think those guys that uh that's so so
much wasted time
guys you know they're they also
it's very difficult when you're in a
competitive business like show business
to pay attention to just yourself and
just like
enjoy your experience and be in the
moment everybody is looking at
themselves
through the eyes of the success of other
people like i remember when i was on
on news radio um the the staff
everybody uh the crew the uh the cast
brother everybody else
besides me had a background in show
business all i had to do
i only had a background stand up i never
taken acting classes other than a few
private classes they made me take
when they gave me a development deal so
i didn't understand the culture
of acting and i remember i was on the
set and they would read variety
or they would read you know whatever
those show hollywood reporter
and they would read about people getting
deals and they would read about how well
friends was doing and how well this is
doing and they get
so [ __ ] mad and uh and i would i
would go why are you
reading that like you're reading the
devil's rag i go you guys are upset
i go last time i checked i'm on [ __ ]
tv
i'm a 27 year old kid and i'm on tv
because that was such a well-written
well-respected show
that didn't get quite the shine that
it should have i felt i felt because
that was a really really really good
show with like a ridiculous level
talented cast and there's always those
things but that's something you have to
learn in this business you just have to
accept
that like you know i always equate a lot
of things to like music that
you know you'll have like some pop star
you know some young
you know guy or girl is going to come
out prime of their life good looking
singing some you know bubble gum [ __ ] is
always going to sell
more yeah than this other thing and you
just have to
you got to be okay with that yeah
because you've got to be like if you
want to sell that
yeah you got it you got to go do that
bubblegum [ __ ] and if you don't want to
do that don't [ __ ] sit there and look
at it
and be upset the comparison is a thief
of joy it's a famous quote but it's an
awesome one
it really is it's you you can't have
that for a while yeah a lot of people do
especially show business show business
that's a common thing
amongst comics it's uh you would see it
this this gleam of jealousy
but i think also a part of this there's
good aspects of jealousy and that
you can feel bad that you're not getting
something that other people are getting
and then it makes you work harder
but then once you've achieved like a
level of success where it's measurable
like where you're like hey look
you're paying your bills you're going
you're doing shows and people coming to
see you like you're doing great
just concentrate on the work then
concentrate on the work don't
concentrate on being at your best don't
concentrate on how well this guy is
doing and how all that
i remember when dane cook was killing it
there was so many haters
and not just because of all the real
reasons to be a hater
but also just because of his success was
so astronomical
i remember people would just fume
thinking about dane cook
selling out arenas it would drive them
crazy
and i remember thinking like just
concentrate on getting better
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between
video and audio experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre
in the background by using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify
app go to spotify now to get this full
episode of the joe rogan experience